but we're going to begin with the
breaking news overnight the new
information on what the fbi says it
found at former president trump's
mar-a-lago home more than 18 months
after he left office it comes in a new
court filing where the justice
department included this photo of
classified documents seized in a search
something we're seeing for the first
time it appears to show
some of the nation's top secrets on the
floor
next to a box of framed magazine covers
including files clearly marked top
secret and marked secret
color coded as well investigators
believe there were attempts to hide this
material from officials who had earlier
come in an effort to recover it
robert costa is outside the justice
department for us bob good morning
good morning tony the big takeaway here
is that this is the most detailed
picture yet of this investigation
revealing much more about what was taken
from former president trump's florida
home earlier this month the filing also
states that obstruction of the probe
could be a problem for trump's legal
team
the justice department spelled out its
position in a 36 page filing the
explosive legal document revealed for
the first time ever photo evidence of
the highly classified documents it sees
from trump's florida home which appear
to show trump was in possession of
intelligence materials derived from
human sources the snapshot marked as a
redacted fbi photograph of documents and
classified cover sheets was recovered
from a container from the so-called 45
office used by the former president at
his sprawling waterfront property which
while protected by secret service is not
considered a secure location for
classified material the filing was in
response to the trump legal team's
request for an independent attorney or
special master to be appointed to review
the evidence that the fbi had already
obtained about two weeks earlier the
justice department forcefully pushed
back against that idea framing it as
unnecessary and legally unsound
writing the former president lacks
standing to seek judicial relief or
oversight as to presidential records
because those records do not belong to
him
former justice department official harry
littman explains what's most striking
about the doj filing the filing besides
making the very strong legal case makes
a pretty strong factual case and gives
us new details that reveal that far from
being cooperative trump tried at every
trick in the book to keep these
documents from going back to where they
belong that is the national archives the
justice department also sharply outlined
a case of possible obstruction against
trump and his lawyers the government
developed evidence that government
records were likely concealed and
removed from the storage room and that
efforts were likely taken to obstruct
the government's investigation the
filing asserts
and it raised questions about whether
trump and his team properly responded to
demands ahead of the fbi search for
documents to be found secured and
returned that the fbi in a matter of
hours recovered twice as many documents
with classification markings as the
diligent search that the former
president's council and other
representatives had weeks to perform
calls into serious question the
representations they made the filing
states but florida federal judge eileen
cannon a trump appointee will have the
final word after thursday's hearing the
judge's order actually seemed to suggest
she was seriously entertaining
appointment of a special master and doj
really pushed back hard and there was
really no legal basis here at all to
appoint a special master so in a polite
way they're telling her butt out
ahead of thursday's hearing which will
be a legal crossroads trump's legal team
has brought on a new attorney chris kais
the former florida solicitor general to
help them navigate the state's federal
courts
bob based on all the details that the
justice department revealed in this
extraordinarily long filing what does it
tell us about where this case might be
going
it tells us that it could be going in a
bit of a new direction toward the
direction of obstruction so far this
case has been about trump's handling of
classified records but this filing
states that this investigation is now
about how trump's lawyers have handled
the investigation how they've interacted
with the justice department that is now
a priority of the probe based on what we
see in this filing
yeah not whether they're classified or
if he declassified them but the fact
that he had them at all and then appears
to have held on to them even after they
were requested bob thank you very much